et d'abord c'est la dernière ligne
droite pour les cadeaux et justement la
prime Noël vient d'être versée aux
ménages les plus modestes uneette
bienvenue alors que l'inflation pèse sur
les budgets cadeau cette année le prix
des jouets n'aurait augmenté que de 2,8
% par rapport à l'an dernier une hausse
modérée mise en relation avec les 6 % de
l'année précédente l'inflation
généralisée grignote le pouvoir d'achat
mais pas de quoi sacrifier Noël à priori
certains se tourne par exemple vers des
solutions plus économiques comme la
seconde main Faustine
luno c'est plus cela ouais ou sinon
c'est la semaine la plus importante de
l'année pour ce commerce du centreville
de tour si jours avant Noël ce magasin
de jouets voit encore défiler les
clients la recherche des cadeaux de
dernière minute bass son plein et
l'attention est porté sur les prix 50 €
par cadeau voilà et avant vous ne vous
fixiez pas de budget
non non avant je dépensais d'habitude à
Noël en général on on dépense pas sans
compter mais enfin on fait pas tellement
attention mais là cette année on fait on
s'est fixé un budget un peu plus précis
auquel on se tient donc ça c'est
différent par rapport aux années
précédentes on fait attention j'ai pas
l'impression de sacrifier mais on on
achète différemment la coupable de cette
vigilance l'inflation généralisée qui
grignote le pouvoir d'achat dans le
domaine du jouet les prix sont
relativement stables hormis pour les
jouets dérivés de film et succès
commerciaux on remarque quand même que
les les grosses pièces tous les jouets
chers entre guillemets en tout cas avec
plus de valeur subissent une
certaine baisse dans dans leur vente par
contre le le volume des ventes et le le
volume des clients lui reste stable
psychologiquement ils ont préféré
prendre des jouets un peu moins chers ou
la boîte avec un petit peu moins de
pièces car le constat en France Mo- 20 €
en moyenne sur le budget des cadeaux de
Noël le poste de dépense le plus
important des fêtes de fin d'année alors
pour ne pas dépasser la somme fixée
certains se sont tournés vers le second
main alors j'achète pas une console
toute neuve c'est pas la dernière sortie
mais oui c'est quasi moitié prix quoi
dans ce magasin spécialisé à chambr et
les tours on remarque cette nouvelle
tendance certaines personnes ne se
tournaient pas vers l'occasion
maintenant en effet ça a vraiment évolué
de façon positive les jouets on va dire
que ça va être peut-être une trentaine
d'articles par jour à peu près une
stratégie pour ne pas sacrifier les
fêtes car cette année les cadeaux
devraient représenter près de 60 % des
dépenses de Noël